duncan is investigating if residents of
a city support the construction of a new
high school he's curious about the
difference of opinion between residents
in the north and south parts of the city
he obtained separate random samples of
voters from each region
here are the results so let's see in the
north 54 out of the 120 said they want
the school 66 said they didn't in the
south 77 said they wanted the school 63
said they didn't
duncan wants to use these results to
construct a 90
confidence interval to estimate the
difference in the proportion of
resonance in these regions who support
the construction project p sub s minus p
sub n so these are the true parameters
for the difference between these two
populations assume that all of the
conditions for inference have been met
all right which of the following is a
correct 90 confidence interval based on
duncan's sample so pause this video and
see if you can figure that out and you
will need a calculator and depending on
your calculator you might need a z table
as well
in a previous video we introduced the
idea of a two sample z interval we talk
about the conditions for inference lucky
us lucky for us here they say the
conditions for inference have been met
so we can go straight to calculating the
confidence interval and that confidence
interval is going to be the difference
between the sample proportions so p sub
s hat so the sample proportion in the
south minus the sample proportion in the
north
it's going to be that difference plus or
minus our critical value
z star
times our estimate of the standard
deviation of the sampling distribution
of the difference between the sample
proportions and that is going to be our
estimate is going to be
p hat sub s times 1 minus
p hat sub s
all of that over
the sample size in the south
plus
p hat sub n times 1 minus p hat sub n
all of that over the sample size
in the north
okay so our sample proportion in the
south i'll later use a calculator to get
a decimal value but this is going to be
in the south we have 77 out of 140
supported so this is going to be 77
out of
140. in the north
this is going to be 54 out of 120
54 out of 120. what is my critical z
value
well here i'm going to have to either
use a calculator or a z table remember
we have a 90 percent confidence interval
and so let me see i'll draw it right
over here if this is a normal
distribution
and you want to have a 90 confidence
interval that means you're containing 90
of
the distribution which means each of
these tails will combine they would have
10 percent but each of them would have
five percent
five percent of
the distribution and so i'm going to
look at a z table that figures out
that figures out how many standard
deviations below the mean do i need to
be in order to
get five percent
right over here and then that's going to
tell me well if i'm that far below or
above that's going to be my critical z
value so let me get that z table out
so i care about five percent and i'm
using this in a bit of a reverse
direction but let's see five
percent
so this is a little over five percent
getting closer to five percent even
closer to five percent now we've gotten
right below five percent so we're going
to be in between this and this i could
just split the difference and i could
just say
1.6
let's just say
1.645 to go right in between
so this is going to be approximately
equal to 1.645
and then let's see we know what p hat
sub s is we know what p hat sub n is in
the south our sample size is 140 and in
the north our sample size is 120. and so
now i just have to type all of this into
the calculator which is going to get a
little hairy but we will do it together
for the sake of time we'll accelerate
this typing into the calculator but i'm
going to start with calculating the
upper bound and then we'll calculate the
lower bound
and then i think i've closed all my
parentheses and so i think we're ready
to get the upper bound
is going to be equal to
0.218 or approximately 0.202
so we can immediately look at our
choices and see where is that the upper
bound and so this one is looking pretty
good 0.202
but let's get the lower bound now so i
got my calculator back instead of
retyping everything i'm just going to
put a minus here so i go to second
and just so you see what i'm doing
second
entry i see the entry back and then i
can just change
i can just change the part
where
right before the radical
so we are going to
all right so this just needs to be a
minus
click enter
and there you have it our lower bound is
is negative
0.002
and that is indeed this choice right
over here so there we go we have picked
our choice